البدايه من التطورات في حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا وتحديدا من خير صلحته بدات
القوات الاخرانيه في تمشيط المناطق التي
انسحبت منها القوه الروسيه لازاله الالغام
والمتفجرات وقد وصف الرئيس الاوكراني
استعاده تاخير سنبالتاريخيه بينما اعلنت
السلطات المواليه لموسكو عن تحديد عاصمه
جديده للمقاطعه بعد الانسحاب من خيرسون
للمتابعه ينضم الينا من شمال
الواقعه تحت السيطره الروسيه مراسل
الجزيره امين درغامي ابدا معك صهيب عن
جديد الوضع في ظل هذا لتصفه ااه كيف بانه
انتصار تاريخي في خيرسون
في الجانب المعنوي وهو كذلك بالنسبه
للاوكران عبد القادر كل المسؤولين من
ابتداء من الرئيس الاوكراني بالادومير
زينسكي يعتبرون هذا يوما تاريخيا بعد ان
استعاده القوات الاوكرانيه سيطره على 30%
من مساحه خيرسون تلك المقاطعه التي سيطرت
عليها القوات الروسيه في بدايتها هذه
الحرب وكانت المقاطعه الاولى والوحيده
التي تسيطر عليها قوات روسيه بالكامل بين
مساحته بنسبه 100% من مساحتها لماذا يعتبر
الاوكرانيون ذلك انتصارا لهم لانهم يقولون
بان اي انسحاب روسي من اي مكان في الاراضي
التي تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه هو بفعل
الضربات اللي اوكرانيه وبالتالي هو انتصار
عسكري بالمعنى العمليات كما يقول
الاوكرانيون ان الذين يقولون بان ما حصل
جاء وفق الخطه المرتبه مصطفى من قبل
القوات الاوكرانيه التي سيطرت على تركيا
حاتم بعد انسحاب القوات الروسيه الان تقول
القوات الاوكرانيه انها تقوم بعمليات
التمشيط لان سيطرت قوات الروسيه لمده شهور
هذا يعني انها خلفت ورائها كميات اسلحه
كبيره وايضا خلفت كم ورائها الغاما كثيره
في عده مناطق لذلك تناشد المواطنين الحيطه
والحذر في ذلك المكان الوحدات الخاصه اول
من دخل الوحدات الخاصه الاوكرانيه بطريقه
الحاله اول من دخل مدينه خيرسون ثم لحقتها
القوات الاوكرانيه الجيش الاوكراني الذي
يقول الان انه سيعيد الحياه الى خرسون
شيئا فشيئا امدادادات الكهرباء والماء
والانترنت والاتصالات وكل ذلك الامر سيكون
خلال الايام القليله القادمه كما يعلن عن
المسؤولون الاوكرانيون اذا المعنى العسكري
هو انعطاف مهم لصالح القوات الاوكرانيه
كما تقول بالمعنى المعنوياته وانتصار كبير
ايضا على المستوى المعنوي وايضا هناك
اشاره مهمه وهي اختياره القوات الروسيه
والسلطات الماليه لها مدينه في اقصى جنوب
شرق خير سون بعيدا 200 كيلو متر عن وسط
مدينه خيرسون هذا يعني سحابا كبيرا كما
يصفه القوه تصفها القوات الاخرانيه لان
القوات الروسيه بذلك من المؤشر بانها قد
تنسحب الى مناطق ابعد من نهر الدبر لكن
يبقى الاهم هو تصريح الرئيس الاوكراني
بلودميرز الانسكي الذي يعتبر ذلك يوما
تاريخيا نستمع لما قاله بالتفصيل
اليوم هو يوم تاريخي لاوكرانيا نحن نعيد
جنوب البلاد نحن نعيد خرسا قواتنا اصبحت
داخل المدينه المواطنون انتظروا جنودنا
انا سعيد جدا على الرغم من التهديدات
الروسيه الناس يخرجون للشوارع ويزيدون كل
اثار العدوان الروسي ستعيد اوكرانيا كل ما
هو كلها قواتنا سيطرت على كل المواقع وسوف
تبدا اجراءات اعاده الاستقرار الى خير
سعود وفي مقدمتها ازاله الالغام لقد تركت
القوات الروسيه الكثيره منها قوات الدفاع
ستؤهل كل شيء وستعود المشافي الى عملها
سنعيد الحياه من جديد
ابقى معنا وتحول الى امين ضرغامي في ماريو
كل بعد المتابعه الروسيه لما يجري في خير
سونامين
[موسيقى]
نعم عبد القادر روسيا وضعت هذه الخطوه اي
خطوه الانسحاب من الضفه اليمنى لنهر نيبر
وضعتها في اطار استراتيجي كان لابد من
اتخاذه رغم ان القياده العسكريه في شخص
قائد القوات الروسيه المشتركه في اوكرانيا
الجنرال سيرجي
صعبه لكن كان من الضروري اتخاذها لعده
اسباب اولها طبعا صعوبات لوجستيه كانت
تواجهها القوات الروسيه على الضفه اليمنى
من نهر النيبرو اضافه الى ما وصفها
بالمخاطر التي كانت تهدد عدد كبير من
السكان في الضفه اليسرى في مدن مثل همم
كخوف كاخرصون وبعض المناطق الاخرى وايضا
همم الحياه القوات الروسيه المنتشره في
تلك المناطق وبالتالي
اتخذت القياده العسكريه الروسيه هذه
الخطوه كما قالت
انتشرت على طول الساحل همم او الجهه
اليسرى لنهر نيبر في خط دفاعيا متقدم
اليوم تم الاعلان كما سمعنا في الخبر عن
همم عاصمه جديده وهي مدينه
المطله على بحر ازوف هذه المدينه من
الناحيه العسكريه
تعد مؤمنه همم يعني اذا ما قررناها بمدن
الاخرى كالنوفو كخوف مثلا التي تقع على
النار ولا في اليوم تعرضت قالت السلطات
المواليه لروسيا انه قسم مدفعي اوكراني
على همم نحو 200 من المدنيين كانوا في
طريقهم الى همم المدينه طبعا كل هذه
التحركات هناك من يرى بان القوات الروسيه
التي انسحبت من الضفه اليمنى من نهر
النيبرو
سيتم ايضا توظيفها في جبهات اخرى كجبهات
زاباروجي هي التي تعد من الجبهات الهادئه
بين قوسين منذ اشهر ولم تشهد معارك همم
وخطوط التماس لم تتغير منذ اكثر من اربعه
اشهر وهناك ايضا من يرى بان تلك القوات
يمكن الدفع بجزء كبير منها الى مقاطعه
دونياس كبير الى تلك المناطق التي استعصت
على القوات الروسيه منذ انطلاق هذه
العمليه العسكريه في فبراير الماضي
يتزام طبعا مع ما كان الانفصاليون قد
اعلنوا عنه امس واليوم بانهم يحققون تقدما
عسكريا كبيرا في محيط مدينه في محور
المطار بسيطرهم على عدد من البلدان هناك
من يربط بهذا التقدم مع اولا القوات اصول
القوات التي كانت ضمن عمليه التعبئه
الجزئيه في روسيا خلال الفتره الاخيره
وهناك ايضا من يقول بان تلك القوات يمكن
عزز بالقوات التي انسحب جزء منها من 30%
من مساحه خرسون همم ربما هناك من يربط
ايضا كل هذا بان همم هناك فصول تنتظر
العمليه العسكريه شكرا او ما تطلق عليها
على الاقل روسي العمليه عسكريه في
اوكرانيا بانها ستدخل فصولا جديده ومعارك
لربما ستكون ايضا محتدمه خاصه في الجبهه
الشرقيه وتحديدا في اقليم جمباز امين درهم
من ماريو وصهيب العصا من كريفيري شكرا
جزيلا لكم